SPEAKER 1: At the City
University of London
in the Centre of Human
and Computer Interaction.
She's done a lot of work
on end user development,
and more recently on
smart homes, and also some
on personal
information management.
So with that, I
hand it over to her.
SIMONE STUMPF: Thanks.
Let's see if I can
bring up these slides,
is it just forward?
Great.
So thanks for inviting me.
My name is Simone Stumpf.
I'm from the Centre
for HCI Design
at City University of London.
And you will be able to
tell that I'm an academic
because my slides look
awful in comparison
to the previous speakers.
So what I'm here to
talk to you about
is how to design
for intelligibility
of smart systems.
And just to introduce
myself, I've
been thinking about this
for the last 15 years.
It's not a new thing that
suddenly has sprung up.
And in terms of my
bio, I've really
looked at supporting
investigators, company
investigators, to spot fraud.
I've also been involved in the
CALO system back in the States,
and that was really
groundbreaking.
It actually produced Siri.
And Adam Cheyer has struck it
rich and I'm still in academia,
but it came out of
that same project.
And really a lot of
what I'll be covering
comes out of an
NSF funding project
that I was part of, which
was called End User Debugging
of Machine Learned Programs.
And we've done a lot of
work around intelligibility,
around controllability, that
I will be talking about.
Other than that,
I'm also looking
at smart heating systems.
And so I'll cover
that very briefly.
I won't be talking about the
stuff I'm doing on a smart home
project, but if you
have any questions,
feel free to talk
to me about that.
So launching into
the meat of this,
what do I think the
issues are for AI
that are coming from HCI?
I think there are three
big aspects to what we
have to try and solve.
This is intelligibility, this is
controllability, and then also
how these two affect or
impact user experience.
And I think there is some work
out there that says, OK, they
are somehow linked,
but we really
don't understand quite
how they are linked
and what to do about them.
So the reason that
these are important,
I think, and particularly
important for AI
systems and smart
systems, is that currently
all those systems, all this
AI, are like black boxes.
They don't really
tell the user anything
about how they work, how
they make their decisions,
what data they're using.
So what happens is that they
are like this bit of magic,
a black art, to users.
So they don't even
have the opportunity
to build a good mental model
of how they actually work.
And that has been the focus of
a lot of UX design previously.
We want users to have a good
mental model so they understand
how systems work
and, particularly,
what to do if they don't do
what they want them to do,
how to fix them when
something goes wrong.
And even though AI
system, nowadays,
have an incredible
accuracy, previous speakers
have covered this.
Well, we're now at sort
of 95% accuracy, right?
But there's still 5%
of, well, it's wrong.
What do you do to fix that?
So what is becoming
increasingly important is, well,
how do we address this
problem of intellibility?
So the way that I use that
term is, well, intelligibility
is all about making
a smart system
understandable by an end-user,
or the user of the system.
So some people have called
it explainability, sometimes
even understandability.
But you know, to me
it's much of the same.
So what is
intelligibility all about?
Well, it's making sure that
they know what the system does,
why it's making those decisions
or displaying that behavior.
And by making it
more understandable,
by making it more intelligible,
hopefully, we also
make it more trustable, and
perhaps even more enjoyable
to use.
So once we have that
understanding by the end-user,
then they should also be able
to fix it if it goes wrong.
Now, how do we get to
intelligible systems?
Well, intelligibility
is really anything
that helps end-users
to make, to build,
these good and
appropriate mental models.
And simply, it could be just
by interacting with the system.
That's quite often how we do
any kind of interaction design.
We just say, OK, you use
the system for a while
and you discover
these features, right?
And that really depends on
the system revealing itself
over time, and that
might be perfectly fine.
But in a complex system
that is supported by AI,
that is supported by machine
learning, that is often not
enough.
And you need a little bit of
a boost to that understanding.
And I would argue
that explanations
have been used in
the past by AI system
to get that to
achieve that, and this
is what I'm going to be talking
about a little bit more--
how to craft explanations
so you give intelligibility
a little boost.
Now, when I use the
term "explanations,"
I include visualizations,
I include pretty pictures,
graphs, and words.
So it's not just some sort of
chat bot gives you the answer,
right?
So let me tell you a little
bit about the history of that.
So explanations have been around
since the 1980s in the old AI
systems, but the sort
of modern AI systems
are much more complex,
like the old ones.
And so you have
that problem, well,
how do you explain the really
complex machine learning
algorithms that are around?
So what has been
shown is that why
or why not explanations
work really,
really well to explain
how these systems work.
And there is some
work around that.
And quite often it's
sort of a mixture
of asking questions
of the system
and displaying some kind
of visualization, very
much like the sort
of facets system
that we saw in the introduction.
However, sometimes
explaining these systems
in terms of why or why
not is really, really
tricky, because what do
you actually explain?
You could explain the data,
you could explain the input,
you could explain the
model that is behind,
you could explain
the output as well.
And really, that is
still an open question.
How do you do that best?
There's some recent
work by Ribeiro
on model agnostic
explanations that's
sort of really storming
the field at the moment.
And that is really quite
interesting to look at,
where it tries to explain a
deep learning system in terms
of the input and output.
That's really
interesting to look at.
What I've been
mainly involved in
is an approach called
explanatory debugging.
And what that combines
is intelligibility
with controllability.
So the intelligibility
is via sort
of an explanation-centric
approach.
We display an explanation of
what their system is doing.
And then the controllability is
where we use these explanations
as a feedback mechanism to help
debug or improve the system.
So it's kind of like
human-in-the-loop learning via
explanations.
We've done some work on it,
and I'll show you a little bit
later, but what we've
also started to do
is, we thought about
the principles that
underlie our approach to
explanatory of debugging.
So we have some
general principles
that we try and design
into any system, right?
And they are principles that
speak to intelligibility.
So we always are iterative
in our explanations,
so the user can actually reveal
the explanation over time
as well.
We are always
trying to be sound.
So we're not going
to lie and explain
the system in different terms.
We might simplify it,
but we're definitely
sticking to what the
model actually does.
We're trying to be complete.
So we include as much
information as possible
to explain how the system
works, so while, obviously, also
not trying to
overwhelm the user.
So we try and explain the
system in fairly detailed,
but simplified terms.
So that's on the
intelligibility side.
And in terms of controllability,
what we're trying to do
is that, all of the things
that we are explaining
are actually actionable.
And quite often
what we're doing is
we're using visualization,
where interacting
with these visualizations feeds
back training to the machine,
to the machine learning system.
We're always reversible,
because the user might be wrong
or what they're doing
has unintended effects.
So this is actually
kind of novel
in machine learning
terms, not in human terms,
but, you know, where the idea
of actually moving training
is kind of unheard of.
We always honor feedback.
So if the user
tells us something,
we do something about it.
We don't just go, oh, you're
wrong, we chuck it away.
And then incremental
changes matter.
So with every kind of example,
with every bit of training data
that we get, we actually
change the model.
So we don't do sort
of that batch training
that is quite often around.
So how do we do that?
So these are the
general principles.
We published a paper in
IUI in 2015 about it.
And here's an
example of a system
that we actually
built to engender
some of these principles.
We called it EluciDebug.
It was kind of a classification,
a text classifier.
It's using the 20 Newsgroups
data set as an example.
And if you just
look in the middle,
it looks very much like
an email client, right?
But what we then added was
all of these explanations
of how that system works.
So we have things in
there about, well,
what is the current training
data that it's looking at?
What is the current prediction
and the confidence level,
or the accuracy level?
What are the features that it
tends to look at right now?
And if you look at this sort of
bar graph down at the bottom,
this displays the weights on
those features, on those words.
And the interesting thing is
that the user can actually
pick up these bars
and move them around
to give the features
more or less weight.
So they are really,
really interactive.
So each of these decisions
is iterative, it is sound,
it is complete, and yet we
think it doesn't overwhelm.
So we evaluated it.
I'll go over that
very, very quickly.
77 participants, they were
not all undergraduates,
but they didn't have any clue
about machine learning systems.
As I said, it was the
20 Newsgroups data set.
They had 30 minutes to make the
system as accurate as possible.
And we were only training
on five messages, right,
which is something that
you usually don't do.
You usually train on a
much larger sample of it.
So we took various measures,
and here's what we found.
Well, it actually works.
They could make the
system much better
in those 30 minutes than
without any explanations.
They did that with
less feedback, right?
So they had to make fewer
changes because they knew
what they needed to change.
And they actually had a
much better understanding.
So compared to no
explanation, they
had a much larger, or
better, mental model
compared to people who
didn't have an explanation.
However, here's what I believe.
There are no cookie
cutter explanations.
So this worked, particularly
for that example.
And we really spent a long time
crafting those explanations
and those visualizations,
but I'm not
pretending that you could
take this exact thing
and plunk it onto
a different system.
It wouldn't work.
Because what we have is
the systems are changing,
the users are changing.
So you have different
smart systems--
SVMs, deep learning,
perhaps even something
that isn't really an AI
system, just very complex.
You might have it in a
different context, right?
So we had a whole desktop
interface to play with, right?
If you have something
like the Nest,
you don't have that space for
all of these explanations,
right?
So you have different
pipes, width of pipes,
for these interactions that
you actually need to consider.
You have different
levels of risk.
I think getting the
temperature wrong on the Nest
is really, really different
to getting a wrong diagnosis
for a cancer patient, right?
These systems have also a
range of different users
that you have to consider
in your UX design, right?
The way that you design for an
end-user versus a domain expert
versus perhaps somebody who's
actually a machine learning
expert needs to be different.
And as always, when
you're doing UX design,
you need to be
aware of the effect
that you want to achieve.
So are you after trust,
satisfaction, perhaps
actually maximizing the feedback
to get that system better?
And all of these need different
kinds of explanations.
So in conclusion, I
think we are all aware
that explainable systems,
intelligible systems,
and intelligibility in general
are really, really important
for research, for
industry, for UX designers,
for machine learning
experts, and also
for users of these systems.
What we really,
really need, I think,
is an increased communication
or increased communication
between AI researchers
and HCI researchers
between designers and engineers.
I think this problem
is really, really not
solvable by one
discipline on its own,
without talking to anybody else.
So what I really would
want is that together we
develop more knowledge
to actually apply
what we're sort of finding
out in research, in practice.
So we end up
building systems that
are intelligible,
that are controllable,
and that have great UX.
And just at the end,
I have a little plug
for a recent workshop
that I was co-organizing,
which was a workshop on
explainable smart systems.
And I'll leave you with
that and take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Questions for Simone?
SPEAKER 3: Thank you.
That was fascinating, and
this controllability thing
seems key in terms of
something like Nest
or an equivalent
of those things.
If you look at, as you
said, the pipe on a Nest,
you can't really
explain width directly.
But did you look at sort of
outsourcing that learning
or controllability
to something else,
as in an app alongside Nest or
some other displaced moment?
Or did you see that the learning
has to happen kind of in situ
at the moment of the
core interaction,
as in changing the temperature?
SIMONE STUMPF: That's a
really interesting point,
because particularly
with the project I'm
doing on a smart
heating system, we
have that problem that you
can't explain everything
in that display.
Explaining the current
decision is possible,
I think, but anything that
needs to be more in-depth,
that's perhaps on
the periphery, I
think we're sort of
thinking of outsourcing
to a different place.
But you still need to know
that you need to explain it.
SPEAKER 4: Simone,
thanks so much.
I was curious what other
provocations you explored other
than to try to
make the system as
accurate as possible
to the participants.
SIMONE STUMPF: For the
explanatory debugging,
we focused mainly
on intelligibility
and controllability, because our
hope was that we could actually
make systems that draw on
the knowledge of users much
better, much quicker, right?
That was the whole
thing about it.
And there are plenty of systems
that operate in that fashion.
So anything that's to
do with personalization,
or something where you don't
have a lot of training data,
right, all of these
systems, I think,
are ripe for explanatory
debugging approaches.
I think this again, coming back
to the smart heating system,
controllability is not it.
In fact, we're going
against a sort of UX mantra.
We don't want users
to feedback a lot,
because these systems
are highly optimized
and we want to stop
users from fiddling
with these damn things, right?
So there, we're actually
trying to use explanation
to make them not fiddle with
the Nest or its equivalent.
So I think it's sort
of different approaches
that need to shift from
context to context.
SPEAKER 5: Hi.
Thank you for the
wonderful talk.
In your research, or what
you've seen in literature,
have you seen
examples, or studies
done, for explainable
systems and how
it might relate in a
user's environment,
such as complex
environments where
there might be a lot
of things going on,
or they're multitasking,
or things like that?
SIMONE STUMPF: Yes, [LAUGHS]
I think explainable AI is
really, really hot right now.
There's a lot of academic
research being done,
and a lot of that is in
very complex environments,
mainly because it's
driven by a huge research
program in the United
States led by DARPA.
So a lot of it is how would you
actually help human and machine
teams to operate efficiently,
to operate at an optimal level.
So there's a lot of
stuff currently going on.
SPEAKER 6: My question
is specifically
about the smart meter heating
systems and explaining
decisions that are made.
Have you yet come across
the privacy implications
of explaining
decisions when objects
that are powered by
these kind of systems
have shared ownership?
So how are you thinking
about that problem?
Because it's something that
preys on my mind a lot.
SIMONE STUMPF: That's actually
a really interesting point,
because currently these
smart heating systems just
display explanations,
even though you usually
have a multiple
occupancy home, right?
And so quite often,
the person who's
in control, who
owns the thermostat,
is the one that gets to
display first, right?
And so I think that problem
hasn't been solved at all.
I think that is ripe
for investigation.
And it's a really,
really good point.
I think also, you know,
what is coming, especially
with the energy networks,
is that you don't even
own your heat anymore.
It's controlled by the network.
They're going to be
switching the heat on and off
whether you like it or not.
SPEAKER 7: Hi, Simone, thanks.
With the editable system,
what was the system
called, the research
that you're doing?
SIMONE STUMPF: EluciDebug.
SPEAKER 7:
EluciDebugging system,
I thought some of
the insights you
had around getting
users to label data
was really interesting.
So was it in the conclusion
that by surfacing, visualizing
what the smart system was doing,
the parameters, users were
more incentivized to label?
And I mean, I think
right now getting users
to just label data as
they're progressing
during the day is a massive
issue in machine learning.
So could this kind of
visualization support
in that aspect?
SIMONE STUMPF: Definitely.
I think there's partly
something about engagement.
Even without explanations,
they were able to label data.
So they could just stick
a label on a message.
Without explanations,
they were actually
able to make these very
pinpointed and targeted
changes.
But they also understood
more where they
needed to make these changes.
So it worked hand in hand, but
there's definitely something
about engagement
in there as well.
SPEAKER 2: We have
time for one more.
Other side of the room.
I was wondering if
we were neglecting,
our bias was against the
far reaches over there?
SPEAKER 8: Thank you.
Great talk.
A question, much of
the explainability,
often we are trying to
get a secondary goal.
Trust, debugging, debuggability,
control, fairness.
We want to show that the
model is fair share and such.
Explainability in complex models
is becoming harder and harder.
I'm not up to date in
all the publications,
but I know it's a
very complex problem.
But many of these secondary
goals, which often is not we
want, those are attractable.
So when should we focus
on explainability,
or instead focus on the
secondary goals which
are more attractable?
SIMONE STUMPF: When you
say secondary goals,
you mean trust?
SPEAKER 8: Trust.
Yes, trust you can attack by
showing results right away.
There are many things we
don't know how it work,
maybe airplanes or
things like that,
but we trust because
they work overall.
SIMONE STUMPF: Well.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 8: Or something that's--
SIMONE STUMPF: So
I think, you know--
SPEAKER 8: Fairness
can be also attacked
without understanding the model.
SIMONE STUMPF: Yes.
However, I would argue that
intelligibility is really
one of the core things
that we need to solve.
You can achieve trust
in some kind of way,
even by just having them
interact with the system
repeatedly.
However, the danger is that
if they don't understand
how the system works and
they encounter something
that they don't like, that
trust is eroded, right?
And intelligibility, I
think, and explanations,
in particular, can
help to give that
a little bit of a boost
to actually cause somebody
to adopt the system.
And then that leads
to trust, right?
Because if they don't adopt
it, if they kind of have
a little look and go, oh,
I don't understand it,
I don't like it, and stop using
it, that can be a problem.
And I think
intelligibility is one
of the cornerstones of that.
SPEAKER 2: I think we're
going to switch over
to-- thank you, Simone.
[APPLAUSE]
I think we're going
to switch over to Dan.
SPEAKER 1: The next
speaker is Dan Hill.
Dan is a designer,
urbanist, author.
Currently he's
Associate Director
of the Arup Group, which is
a strategy interdisciplinary
service, also working
as advisors to some
of the innovation issues
of the UK government.
Thank you.
DAN HILL: Thank you.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
Housing Co-Op, which
is around the corner from here.
I urge everybody to go to it.
I'll explain why later.
That's where I was
yesterday afternoon.
So I'm a designer,
as you could see,
because I left my
slides up there,
and they were
exposed to condition.
You could see, well,
actually it's--